[Música]
para que voy a estudiar si los gobiernos
no escuchan a quienes si estudiaron de
qué me sirve ir a la escuela si los
adultos me están van a dejar un mundo
inhabitable y desolado este fue el
planteo que se hizo una adolescente
sueca greta thunberg cuando decidió que
todos los viernes en vez de ir a la
escuela iba a ir al parlamento sueco a
pedir que los adultos tomen la acción
urgente y responsable frente al cambio
climático
usted voz voz
todos nosotros somos la primera
generación inmersa en el cambio
climático pero también somos la última
que puede pararlo
hace unos 5 años 12 eventos casi
simultáneamente modelaron me presenté
y juntos son los que iniciaron el camino
que me trae hoy acá a compartir mi
historia
el fallecimiento de mi madre que me
convierte a un propietario de un campo y
una experiencia que tuve durante un
curso de transformación social
la teoría que modificó radicalmente mi
rumbo
tener el campo era la solución mejor
no tenía idea cómo trabajar lo que daba
el hijos era una económica chica
sin embargo sentir la responsabilidad
por esta tierra que había llegado a mí y
el deseo de regenerar la
y decidí no vender
la experiencia de la teoría en un
ejercicio nos proponían mirar con
nuestro corazón lo que el futuro
proponía para nuestras vidas y si
queríamos imaginar una puerta y tras
ponerla para verlo
lo hice
frente a mí una vegetación verde
exuberante vibrante viva
inexplicablemente en ese momento tuve la
certeza de que mi vida había tomado un
cambio inexorable no sabía qué hacer
sin embargo me fui dejando llevar y
gradualmente todo fue acomodándose el
campo mi interés por la sustentabilidad
y el cambio climático y mi colaboración
con el movimiento 'slow food' que
protege la biodiversidad desde los
alimentos
con el campo me acerqué a la
agroecología aprendí de sistemas
alimentarios aprendí de los problemas de
la de la tierra y las semillas nativas y
junto con eso me acerqué al drama de los
fumigados desde otro lugar
escuché testimonios de primera mano vi
fotos puse caras a lo que el agronegocio
llama externalidades
avanzar en este tema
y va develando una una magnitud
impensable para mí desde donde yo venía
como podía ser que no habíamos leído
nada en los medios porque como yo que
era una persona que más o menos me
ocupaba y sabía que era un tema en los
campos para la tierra y que había que
tener cuidado para aplicar no tenía
conciencia de semejante ecocidio
decidí que mi lugar estaba en la ciudad
haciendo saber lo que pasa en el campo
tendiendo puentes mis redes se
convirtieron en mi voz porque no era mi
campo el que había que cambiar eran
todos los campos
que podría ser yo empecé a contarle a
quien se me cruzaba y me quería oír lo
que estaba pasando en el campo a
proponer porque no cambian sus compras y
compran otras cosas porque no hacen
huertas
y por qué no tratan de adoptar el modelo
agroecológico como sistema de producción
la verdad yo no soy experta en ninguno
de esos temas pero hoy hay unas 2.000
hectáreas de campo que se trabaja en
distintos gracias a conversaciones que
se iniciaron así
en casa comíamos agroecológicos y había
había y si no nos todo este conocimiento
de repente para mí espanto en realidad
me doy cuenta que los cultivos que nos
enferman en el campo entran a mi casa de
mi mano a través de mis compras de
alimentos y bebidas ultra procesados en
forma y carnes industriales
desde sus paquetes multicolores nos
dicen comerme pero los ultra procesados
no se enferman
contienen ingredientes químicos que nos
hacen mal contienen aditivos contienen
conservantes
y el azúcar
todos sabemos lo mal que hace el azúcar
pero saben que hay 30 variedades de
nombres de azúcar agregado para los
productos ultra procesados como sabemos
que estamos comiendo
aunque le damos las etiquetas maikel
polar que es un periodista que escribe
sobre alimentación nos dice si tiene más
de cinco ingredientes si tu abuela
bisabuela no reconocería en alguno o si
tiene un paquete no lo compres reeducar
a nuestra familia para que cambiar la
alimentación es un tema que no es menor
los ultra procesados no nos educan la
boca para que sea difícil en casa vamos
a tener un montón de oposición cuando
queramos cambiar pero
es un proceso lento pero pero se puede
hacer
mi hijo me decía todo el tiempo mamá
porque no hay galletitas en casa cuando
cuando vamos a comer algo normal en esta
casa hoy entiende por qué comemos cómo
lo hacemos y lo comparte con sus amigos
hacer una huerta
era parte del proceso para adquirir la
soberanía alimentaria junto con varios
amigos decidimos empezar a hacer una
huerta a mí no me creció nada
entonces un día agarré todas las
semillas que tenía y me dije las mezcle
y dije bueno hagan lo que ustedes
vinieron a hacer la sembré todas juntas
sólo salieron tomates y perejil pero en
este camino que aún tengo mucho por
recorrer vi a mi hijo tomar un tomate de
nuestro balcón y comerlo
hace 25 años que hago compost pero en
este despertar se convirtió en una
enorme una parte de un círculo virtuoso
que genera vida y suelo en vez de gas
metano en un basural
con mi amiga paula
nos propusimos generar un espacio de
alimentación saludable y sustentabilidad
en el colegio de nuestros hijos
convocamos a otros padres y madres y al
poco tiempo éramos unas 100 personas
trabajando en el tema
hicimos eventos un recetario de
alimentación saludable visitamos huertas
trabajamos con el colegio en el comedor
escolar y hoy mil chicos docentes y
empleados pueden comer rico y sano las
charlas sobre sobre alimentación nos
llevaron a la sustentabilidad y la
sustentabilidad nos llevó a reflexionar
sobre nuestros valores como comunidad
a medida que avanzaba en entender más el
sistema alimentario me di cuenta que los
intereses económicos dominaban el tema a
nivel global hay un sistema alimentario
global que está compuesto por fondos
comunes de inversión y grandes
corporaciones que ven a la producción de
alimentos como la forma de generar
ganancias para sus accionistas no les
interesan los alimentos sencillos yo lo
sé bastante porque trabajé en este mundo
diez empresas deciden lo que podemos
comer y cuatro empresas deciden las
semillas que se van a usar son semillas
de paquetes tecnológicos ahora yo me
pregunto
puede un sistema que se basa en
monocultivos venenos economías de escala
y comoditización a costa de nuestra
salud y nuestro hábitat ser quien nos
alimente yo creo que no por suerte en
argentina hay muchos productores
conscientes los tenemos que buscar
apoyarlos con nuestras compras es
convertirnos en parte de un sistema
virtuoso que tiene una mirada
egocéntrica de la producción y de la
tierra
cada cambiar nuestra alimentación es
expresar cómo queremos vivir mejorar
nuestra salud tiene reduce nuestro
impacto en el planeta y en directamente
nos ayuda a cuidar las semillas nativas
cada uno de nosotros
es libre de elegir cada día que va a
estar
cada acción individual es importante y
necesaria va tejiendo redes generando
consensos multiplicándose
fortaleciéndose
hay una lucha posible mientras esperamos
que se definan políticas públicas desde
nuestra
desde nuestra cocina y con nuestras
compras ayer en el congreso miles de
chicos como grietas nos pidieron que nos
hagamos responsables por el cambio
climático y la sustentabilidad
y es por eso que quiero compartirles hoy
el gran secreto del guerrero del tenedor
para cambiar radicalmente el sistema
alimentario y reducir nuestro impacto
ambiental tenemos que volver a la cocina
a cocinar por placer con ingredientes
ricos sanos limpios de agrotóxicos de
pequeños productores que conozcamos
locales de estación esa es nuestra
bandera diaria esa es nuestra pancarta
la levantamos desde casa cada día cuatro
veces por día demos vuelta el sistema un
bocado por vez
[Aplausos]
[Música]